This presentation is delivered by the Stanford Center for Professional Development.
Yes. Right. OK. Hello, everyone, welcome to the 16th annual Christmas Tree Lecture.
I don't know how many of you have ever been at a previous Christmas tree lecture. Phew.
OK. Going to see a lot of friends here, too.
So the idea is that every year about this time I try to give a lecture about the coolest thing I learned about trees during here.
The trees are a sort of computer scientist, best, best friend.
And so every year there's there's always something new to new to say.
And let's see, the title today is is Why Pi and I and I learned just an hour ago that might title wasn't as original as I thought.
Let's go to Google and and and see this here.
Oh, by the way, before I before I forgot, I have to say I have to say that that today is a very special day for me because I just finished it.
Yeah. Let's see how my. Which program I'm talking huge SSAFA here.
OK? I'm not moving so slow.
So I just finished actually for the first time in my life and probably the only time in my life, I finished two books on this, an exact same day.
And and and exactly today this book selected papers and fun and games is being got going off to a printer in Chicago.
And another book called The Art of Computer Programing Volume for A is going up to a printer in Massachusetts.
So it just it just happened that that both of them are taking place today and saw it.
So I'm a quick kind of celebrating.
And also I'm going to have to go into input mode instead of output mode for a while,
because the total pages are once he had 900 pages in it, in one in the art of computer programing and 1750 in this one.
So. So I'm about Page Dot now, but I put it.
It took me many years to write these books. Of course. OK, so so now let's go to Google and let's try the title.
Why Pi. Because I thought it was original and I never even checked to see how it was.
But it turns out there's lots of there lots of things even, you know, I don't know stuff about.
I think you did the. Yeah, we didn't get it.
We did get a little bit about it. OK. So and so here's what where you find out that actually this you know, people have been tweeting about it.
And so I thought so. So maybe out there in the in Web land, there are huge number of people who knows.
Let's hope it doesn't crash danford server. But we'll see. So why pi?
How does. Let's say, first of all, why do as pi relate to trees?
So, so many times in the past I've I've talked about the number of number of trees that you can that you can do with end nodes.
So let me see if we can get on to this. This other device here, see how the notepad works.
You switch to this cup. Good. So, for example, there are two.
There are two trees with two nodes, actually forests.
Let's say this is one. And this is the other where this just means the forest can just consist of two separate trees and an ant.
But each tree is just a root. Nothing else. But here's here's a tree that has a root and one they Senate.
So there's two there's two of them. One equals two and course only one when N equals one through these for us.
What. Well, when N equals three there's five a forest. There's, there's this one which is three nodes all by himself.
Then there's this one. We also consider this to be different because they're ordered.
And then there's something like this. And one more.
Anybody. Anybody. Think of another one. What?
Yeah. That's going all the way down. OK. So there's five there.
OK. So. So the the number of of the forest within nodes is called the Catalan number.
It's very famous. Occurs in lots of places. And so what happens is actually might as well make it make a table here.
And. And we should we should start it at zero instead of instead of one.
You see, I can learn the zooming this looming feature. OK.
So OK. So so we start at zero and then one, two, three. And so how many of forests are there with zero nodes.
There's one. OK. And there's one, two, five.
And it continues on 14 and so on. Very fascinating secrets.
A number. And the actual. There's a formula for it. And that is two N factorial divided by an factorial and plus one factorial.
Now, I better explain what a factorial is, although if you if you've never seen vectors before,
it might be you might have a lot more questions than if you have, but.
So, for example. Well, in fact, are I just the product of the numbers went up to N and zero factorial.
Is is is the product of all the numbers went up to zero, which is empty products.
So it's one. So let's let's check it out. When N equals three.
That would mean six factorial over three factorial. Four factorial.
So that would be one times two, three, four, five, six. And then we divide by one, two, three.
And then one, two, three, four. And and so that the one, two, three, four cancel.
And this one, two, three cars with the six. And so it comes out to be five.
See, that's that's the formula. OK, now. But but PI gets into this too, because it turns out that this is approximately four to the N.
Over. The square root of Pi n.
In plus one. Let's see. I could also right square to pay and.
OK. So now. For example.
Well, let's let's let's check it out on it.
Let's check it out on the Internet, because I got to learn the technology, all of this of this lecture room as I'm giving this lecture.
So I'm going to go to my computer now and try. SML. Oh, let's see.
Yes. OK. So, Michael, go to Wolfram Alpha.
OK. OK. So now. OK.
OK. So. So we say let's take N equals a thousand.
Right. So. So two thousand factorial divided by 1000 factorial.
All right. And then also a big divide by one thousand one factorial.
OK, so there we go. This is the. This is the number of us on a thousand nodes.
And let's see what it says. OK, there it is.
And and it's approximately, you see 2.0 for six. Ten to the five.
Ninety seven. OK. OK. Now I'll spawn another. I'll spawn another window and try to get Wolfram Alpha on that one too.
And then I'll try the other guy. Yeah.
OK, so so here are four to four to the story, four, four to the 1000 divided by the square root of of.
One thousand pine. And divide that by 2001.
OK. So what? OK, so curious here, they let let's see how close how close we got here.
Is it working? How can I make it OK?
So, yeah, you want to screw this up?
Sorry I should've practiced this before, but I just want to.
I want to get that guy there, right? And then I went to.
Bring the other screen up, shrink it or something. Let's see, what can I do here?
Why did I get help from Madobe on this? Who knows?
OK. So anyway, it's it's not going to certainly match to all those all those places.
But it but it should match pretty well. So let's see what we do here.
I'm on my quest, Mike, Mike. Mike, talk should be why didn't Knuth practice in advance?
OK. So here we go. Two hours, four six one one five five two, two, four, six, three.
OK, well, we now anyway, the leading digits.
All right. OK. And if I hadn't put square to pioneer, it would have been so close.
Of course. And we could try it. If I had more time with ten thousand one hundred thousand.
So I would find out that somehow pi has something to do with trees.
Well, this is this has always been a mystery. I think to everybody why that's why PI should occur in connection with forests.
It just seemed to be one of those strange coincidences affects the nature that, well, there is a constant and.
And lo and behold, it agrees with PI to any number of decimal places.
So it must be pi or square root of pi in this case. Well, however.
Two years ago, a guy in Sweden named Johan Westlund figured out why and where he published the.
He published work and it's Guy. I'm going to write his name down because I think he's watching from Sweden at this very moment.
I mean, it's it's the middle of the night there.
But but still, he said he was going to try to watch it.
So I'm really nervous because I'll get this right.
But but he published this in the American Math Monthly.
Was it December two thousand seven?
Well, I said two years ago. I'm sorry, three years ago and it's on pages nine, 14 and I'm 17.
And so he's on. Yes.
So so his article. Actually, I didn't see it, though, until a year later because I'm always a year behind reading stuff like this.
And up and up. And he figured out, I think for the first time, a reason why circles have something to do with with Vectorial.
And and so I'm gonna try to explain right now. And fortunately, it's really not that complicated.
So it's it's quite beautiful. And I asked him, how did he ever come up with this?
So he told me that it was actually it was actually six years ago.
He was trying to figure out some some questions to ask on the Swedish Math Olympiad.
This is a test for high school students in Sweden and up.
And so he and he was thinking about a problem that Paul Hamos had mentioned in his book.
Paul Thomas has a book called Problems for Mathematicians, Young and Old.
And one of the problems that that Hamish asked was, was this I suppose you could you could take a design,
a dye that wouldn't roll each face of the dye with equal probability, but instead it had six faces.
But but it was it worked out that it got.
If you rolled two of these dice, you would get the numbers two, three, four, up to 12, all with the same probability.
And that's so, so. So how much that is it possible to do that?
So let me show you what that means geometrically, if I can. I guess I got a I got to now come to another thing.
Let me let me go to preview here. That should that should be good. OK.
So preview fire. Open.
OK. So now I went to the desktop wrasslin part.
Here we go. Wristlet. OK. So.
Page one, please. OK, so so here's here's the deal.
I got six probabilities for the six faces, P1, P2 and so on,
up to be sick and I want somehow the probability of getting the same if P1, P2, P3 also occur on the other on this other axis.
I should probably put it in there, too. And so the probability that I get two ones is P1 times P one.
And so. So this big, this big square here, that's the area that is is the probability that I'm going to shake.
I would roll a tube.
If I roll to these days then to roll a three, I have to get either a one or a one on the first day and then two on a second or a two and a one.
So. So this rectangle plus this rectangle is is also supposed to turn out to be the same area as the other two.
And in fact, in fact, it is because I can tell you now that if you if you call this number a square, then then this is just half as P2 as half of P1.
And so you get these two guys and you get the same area. And so then he also wants these three squares to add up to be the same,
because this is the probability that you shake the floor with with two these dioceses, you know, one.
Three or two. Two or three. One. And and so on.
And so so this purple guy here is the probability that you shake a twelve.
It doesn't look like it's gonna be it's gonna make it very way up.
And how much his book. He gives it. He gives it a tricky proof that it's impossible to design dice that would do this.
And but it's a complicated it's a proof that it's sort of nice and short, but it uses a very loose,
complex numbers, in fact, and unique factorization of polynomials and things like that.
And Johan was saying, well, maybe a high school students would could approach a problem a different way,
say if if we're gonna try to make these rules all come out equal.
What do we have to do? So let's see of what it means.
It says that P1 squared is going to have to equal. P one, P two plus P2P one.
So in other words, that's going to that's going to mean that P two is going to have to equal one half P one.
OK, then let's try. It's also going to have to equal P one, P three plus P2P to.
This is the probability of shaking a four p. 3p one.
And so that so. Well, it. That's equal then of course.
Too few one P three plus one fourth P, one squared.
Plus P 3p one. And so we have to, you know, we have to solve that.
And it turns out. That turns out that that's going to mean that Pete three is equal to three eighths of P1.
Factor of P, one out of all of all of these, and you get P one equals P three plus P three plus one fourth, P one.
So there you are. Three quarters. Half. A three course. So. So well. And so on.
P one. P for up to P4P one.
And you work it out. Because we've already figured out what P2 and P3 are.
And it turns out that P four is equal to thirty five over 128 P1 and.
Sorry. That's P five. P four is was fifteen over 16 of P one and P five was thirty five over 120.
So we get these, we get these these coefficients.
And now the interesting thing, if if you're just playing around with it, we see that that actually week we can do it at least up up to this step.
Well, the weekend. This is for rolling to this three or four and so on.
Up to rolling seven. So so we can make we can make all of those all of those six possibilities from two to seven, all equally likely.
And it's unique. In fact, if once we choose once we choose P one, that then we know what P2P three and six.
OK. Now if we're gonna go any further, then it's gonna turn out that we just don't have any wiggle room anymore.
So this will prove that it's impossible and self how his problem with it, with a low level approach instead of a instead of a high level approach.
Now, but note these numbers. You look at these numbers and they're they're kind of interesting.
Notice it is only only small prime factors here.
The denominator effect is always the power of two and the numerator never has anything bigger in the seven.
As far as the primes in it. So if you look at a little more. This is one half than three eighths.
Happens to be one half times three quarters and fifteen sixteen turns out to be one half times three quarters times five, six.
And. And you might notice a pattern at this point.
What do you think is P five is going to be. Nobody gets it.
Come on, shout it out, shout it out. OK. So, yeah.
OK. So, yeah.
You see that we're just writing the numbers, though. We're not quite calculating in factorial.
We'd have one times, two times, three times where we were putting even what guys in the denominator and odd guys numerator.
But here we are. You know, certainly a pattern net that calls for further investigation.
And so and so you I started looking at the pattern and and you say, well, first of all, let's.
Well, let's prove this. Prove the pattern. What? But but before I let you.
You might as well you might want verify that that works. And so what I'm what I'm going to do now is I'm going to say P.J.
Equals a J minus one times P one.
I'm gonna no, I'm I'm gonna not call AJ times P one.
Because, because the formula for four for P two had one term in it and the Permian for P three at two terms.
And it's I'm going to say there's J minus one terms in the thing, so I'm gonna try to try to see what this is and so on.
And so a zero is equal to one. And a a one was equal to one half and so on.
We had three eights and and so now it lets we form this this infinite series, a zero plus a one time C plus A to Z Square, a 3000 cubed and so on.
And that's called this function A of Z. And the reason I do this is because I'm going to square it and.
And I want to apply this series by itself. And what do I get?
I get a zero. A zero for the constant term. And then the coefficient of Z is a zero.
A one plus a one. A zero. And the coefficient of Li squared is, of course, just what we were doing before.
Pretty much without factoring out the P1. OK.
So. So this is actually equal to one plus ze.
Plus the square, plus the it's supposed to be one in every case.
That's what he's a he's a numbers dude. And so this is equal to one over on minus Z that this infinite this infinite series is is easy.
It is a geometric series. And the value is one over one minus C.
So great. Because then I know what ANZ is ANZ is this is plus or minus the square.
The square root of of that.
So. So this original series where we were trying to figure out what the what the little aser happens to be,
the series four one over the square root of one minus C.
And of course, I have to choose the plus sign here because I said a zero was equal to one.
The constant term is equal to one. So, so, so. So this is it.
And we have the binomial theorem that says that if you have one minus C two any power,
the answer is a a series that goes up to infinity that has minus.
OK. Then you write it a little slower. This is one minus Z to the minus one half power.
So you can always expand the binomial to a power even when the power is messenger and the binomial coefficients come up there and it's minus one half.
Choose K less use N, I guess in times of Z at the end.
So in other words, ace sub and is equal to minus one half full.
Sorry. Minus Z to the end. That was. Minus two, the.
Because I have minus C and seven plus. So.
So the idea is that net eight ace of N is equal to Moscow, minus one half.
And we're in times minus one to the ends power. And so let's look now.
You might not all be familiar with binomial coefficients in this window of practice like this.
But they're actually quite simple. Here's what it means. Let's try a A three, for example.
A three is equal to minus one half of it.
Like in general, when you have a binomial coefficient, you you start with this guy and then you subtract one and two and keep on subtracting
one until you have in terms and then you divide by three times two times one.
So this is the this is the. And then we kind of multiply this by minus one cubed.
So that's what, minus one half. I choose three years and and I get rid of the minus signs.
Right. But by changing all these guys to plus. So what I really have is one one half over three.
Three have over two and five halves. Right. Right. So one half times.
Three 1/2 times five halves. And then the denominator.
I can write in the other order. One, two, three. Is it a three to one is the same deal.
So that's one over two times. Three over four times five over six.
That's the pattern that we saw. OK. So, so, so, so we got it.
Nice proof of that. All right. Now. In order, however, that that just determines the ratio between between P2 and P3 and so on and P1,
we still have to make you think this supposed to be probabilities. We want to P1 we're the sum of those six probabilities to equal one.
OK, so so so this is supposed to equal one.
But this is equal to P1 Times, P1 squared times a zero plus a one up to a five.
And so in order to figure out what P1 is, I have to have to know what this sum is, whether it was the sum of of all these guys.
Well, that is. That is very nice, actually,
because if I have if I have any infinite series like this and I want to know what what the summit with the sums are of the cover,
the coefficients, I just modify the infinite series. OK.
So I take AVC. I'm all applied by one Plessey. Was you squared.
Etc., And I get a zero. And then here I get a zero plus a one.
The coefficient is squared. I get a one.
I get the sums there that are there. OK.
So now, actually, I'm going to I'm going to call this one plus s to the and so on as three Z squared,
because I'm interested in s six four the six sided dice.
So the coefficient of Z of the Fifth is actually this is six here.
The sum of S six is the sum of a zero through a five.
And and then going back to what I had, I said that P one squared.
Times. Six is equal to one. That's the sum of the six probabilities.
So I have to figure out what.
What what is? And and but that's that's easy because this we know the AFC was won over.
That was one minor to the minus a half power. And and this thing is one over one minus three.
So that's minus one one minus C to the minus one power. So that so.
So I'm left with one line to see to the minus three FS power. And so this is just a you see the summation of minus three halves to the end.
Times minus times minus three to the power and the coefficients of zie.
Here then are just again coming out of the pattern. All right.
Well, so it's it's never it's never easy to do math in front of an audience or or what to watch.
I like this step by step. And ladies, this is the the point is now there's gonna be a great pattern on the some of these numbers to an end.
In fact, here's where it is. So we started out we had a zero equal to one.
A one equals one half. A two is is is a three eighths, and so I know if we add if I add this together, S1 is was equal A.
A zero is equal to one as two is going to be the sum of the first two guys.
And that's equal to three halves. And as three is the sum of the first three guys, you know, a zero, not a two.
And that add three ace to that.
And what do you get? This is this is twelve eights, 15 eights.
Right. Okay. So. So anyway, this is three have times five fourth.
And guess what? Six is three 1/2 times.
Five force times, seven. Six and nine, eight.
And and we're going to have a. Five terms in there, I guess.
Eleven. Eleven. Ten. OK.
And. So there's a nice formula then for the SS, as well as the sums of these of these guys as well as the others.
This is gonna this is gonna. This is as hard as it gets as far as proving that pie gets in into the action.
But but it it's it's an easy pattern to prove by induction.
However, this different series method explains why this pattern is really there and and why why such a simple pattern should occur in these numbers.
OK, let's see. Now, I.
I see people standing in the back, you know, actually there's some good seats over here to make if you want to, if you wanna come up.
But also I wanted to mention that there's there's gonna be a prize at the end of the hour for the person who asked the people
who I got about six books there and the people who asked the best six questions during the hour are entitled to these books.
So may I ask if there's any questions at this point?
Everybody understands so far with what I've been doing, I'm going to give you another picture now so that we take.
OK. So, so, so here you kind of move now and see, I even need this.
I might as well go to Michael, go here.
So for here I've got 10 instead of six and I threw out the I threw out I you know, I threw out the guys that weren't going to be equal probability.
But if I had a 10 sided dice, I could do the same thing.
And I could make sure that all of the all of the first sums of of two things would have equal area and the and the numbers.
A zero or a nine.
You know, give me the the the sizes of these rectangles that this here's a rectangle is a three by a one about two or a two by a zero and the at.
And then the S is tell me the sums up to this point.
So it's ten is is the you know the width of this whole thing is s ten.
Now you see what the area of the red is is this one.
Now what about this, this brown. The total area of the two brown guys is two is one also.
Each one is a half. And, you know, here's this one is three eights.
This one is three eights, and this one is is one quarter.
And so that adds up to one also. So it's like. I got it in the colored things here.
I got I got 10 things. Each of every one.
So so the cup. So the area of these colored rectangles is exactly 10.
With me, but now Yohann noticed that it also looks very much like a circle.
So here I have I have a circle of radius, has 10 and.
And if we zoom in on this, you know, we see that it actually is is it, you know, very, very close to it.
So so so I've got these rectangles that are that are not only do the rectangles have nice expressions for how wide and tall they are,
these these fractions that we get. But also it's very close to a circle.
You see you see you see what's happening here is that the circle is crossing over exact.
Is it all of these purple guys are getting cut. Exactly. Exactly.
By the same. It's always coming. It's always cutting. That was never getting into the blue.
All right. Now, of course, this is only the case N equals 10.
So let's let's see what happens if we go up a little bigger before like before I lose this slide, though,
I want to mention one formula that that is is useful and that is the SRN is equal to two end times and.
Nice formula, you know.
In other words, S. S. One is supposed to equal twice a one.
And as too is supposed to equal four times a two and so on.
So that looks that looks right. And s ten would be ten times a ten.
We didn't actually need a ten in this picture, but 20 times a ten.
But but you know, if we had calculated a ten it would have it would have been just one twentieth of the of this of this total with.
So that's another way to get at these at these triangles. And once we and until we can sort of bootstrap to the next guy.
So. So for now, let's take a look then at what happens if I do down.
So so this was the case that we just looked at with ten. And now we could add another another 10 guys in here.
And so now we get up to 20. And this will be the area, the total area of the rectangle.
Serious, 20. What? Oh, I'm sorry. Can you take.
Can you get onto my computer screen? Jason.
Guys went to sleep, I think. I'm okay.
Oh, yeah. You got it. Okay. So, yeah, this is a, uh.
OK. So here's a 10 that we were looking at, and now we can add another rule to another row of 10.
And so we get 20 here. And the radius of this, this guy is as 20 now.
And now we know the area of these rectangles is 20.
Because each each of these Rikk rings in the rectangle White has area.
Exactly. One. And and it's also, you know, then we get 30 and 40 and 50 and 60.
And still, if we if we look closely at the at the at the thing, it's it it's dark circles just cutting right in there.
Each of the it includes all of the blue rectangles.
Second from the top. And it's cutting the purple guys at the edge into parts and then it's not.
But the circle never, you know. And it also gets a little bit into the into the into the white at the next level.
OK. So that's what happens then. If and increases and it looks like it looks like then that we got a really good approximation to the circle.
And that's that's the next thing that would that we have to prove. OK. So now now there's a really beautiful proof of that too.
But let's let's let's take stock. First of what we what we done then.
So we have it. I'm going to come back to my pad now.
And what we've done is we have a rectangular area in. And and that is approximately equal to the area of a circle.
And that's where pie comes in because that's where the definition of pie.
Well, there's two definitions. One is that it's the ratio between the circumference of a circle and the diameter of a circle.
But but the other equally good definition is it's. It's the fork.
It's the constant that occurs when you get the area of a circle, which is PI times are squared.
So now here we have not a whole circle, but it's a fourth of a circle. So so end is approximately one fourth of S and square.
And and in fact, if we can prove that.
How good does it surprise me if we can prove that that the circle always cuts, the always cuts the rim?
As as we as we noticed there, so it's always coming through here. In every case, it talk.
So, yes, it does. I read every rectangle on the edge. It's getting cut on the top edge and the right edge.
Then this has to be less than and plus one and greater than N minus one because we've got N minus one.
If we stay totally within this, within this region and we get and we got N plus one,
if we if, if we, if we take, if we add another layer to the thing on the outside.
So, so. So if I can prove this, that the circle actually has this property that if that it stays outside of the internal juice
and inside of the outer notches on his inner notches here and outer notches are these guys.
And so if the circle always lies between the out the inner notches in the outer notches,
then we then we then we have this nice formula for exactly how well the rectangles are approximating the true circle area.
You got a question? You're missing a part. You know, I was right there.
But we just didn't see it. Now.
I would like to. I would like to say that I did it on purpose to see if anybody was watching.
But but anyway, since you did it, why don't you come up afterwards and get one of these books?
Any other questions? All right.
Yeah, actually, that was I guess your question was why not pi?
I'm like, OK, so the notation you're also using two different ways.
Oh, I'm using N in two different ways. Yes. Is that bad.
Yeah. So. So. So what is S and S n is the radius.
If I've done this, if I've done this construction and times suck.
So in the last picture and was 60 and 60 was the radius and the area of the rectangles in that case was 60.
Because each, each rim has area of one. So, so, so, so it's OK to use and and in those days.
But if I hadn't, then I would have some problem because I have to because I have to relate.
You know, this was s.m then I wouldn't have proved anything. OK.
Other questions. So so now now we come to the acute proof that it actually it really does correspond to a circle.
And so what I want to do is first I want to show I want to show the relation between between s.
Well, let's look. Let's consider, for example, s nine squared and S six squared.
So so. S six squared. Let's see what X is. Six squared is.
And let me remind you what Essex's in the first place.
It was three halves. Let's get it right here.
Three has times. Five force times, seven, eight times.
Nine, ten, eleven, twelve. What say?
Seven, six, nine, eight, 11 tense.
Good. OK. It ends well, always with. It always ends with two and it always ends with two and minus two.
Yeah. OK. And up as nine squared is gonna be OK.
Then I square this. OK, so I square this.
Each of these terms, two s nine squared is gonna be s six squared.
And then we got three. Three more guys. Thirteen. Twelve squared.
Fifteen. Fourteen squared. And seventeen.
Sixteen squared. Now, I'm going to show that actually there's a nice relation between these these things and the soap.
Well, it depends on is the following. If I take if I take a number, that's one plus one over to.
K squared. Which is which, you know, the all of these numbers are examples of that Cagle's six, seven, eight.
In this case here, this is this is, of course, one plus one over case squared plus one over four case square.
So. Forget that key one over Kay, plus one plus one over Caples, one for K squared.
And this is well it's bigger than one plus one over K, for example.
OK, so then I can say then that s nine squared is is is bigger than as six squared times
one plus one over six times one plus one over seven times one plus one over a.
Right. Because here I took cake was 13. Twelve squared is bigger than one plus one six.
And similarly with here. OK, but.
But what. But ah. This is seven, six times eight sevens.
Times nine, eight. And it's all canceling. So this is equal to six squared, times nine sixth.
So somehow S. S nine squared is is just, you know, it is going to be bigger than than nine six.
But we can also approximate the other direction. And we say that one plus two one over two K squared is less that is.
Well again one plus one over K at this time. I'll get it right.
Plus one over for squishier. And this is less than I claim.
One plus one over K plus one over K squared plus one over KQ plus one plus one over K to the fourth and so on, all the way to infinity.
Why is that. Because well one over four K squared is, is, is less than one over K times K minus one.
This, this infinite series here that I substituted here was K, K, K, K minus one and STK.
That's equivalent to saying that four K is bigger than K minus one, which is which is quite obvious.
I'm assuming that case is greater than one.
So if kids equal to one, then I get infinite infinity here, which is certainly less than six or so case greater than one and six.
OK. So, so but this is equal to K minus one over K, K over K minus one.
It's just the you know, again, some of it it's it's one over one minus one over case.
And if we take one over Cadabby Z. and then the formula that I had this this is one over one minus one over K,
which is the same as K over CamNet slot. So, so, so therefore s9 nine squared is greater than is less than.
As six squared times put cakehole six, we get six Fyffes and then seven, six and then eight sevens.
So, again, the cast thing is going on, but now we're left with a six squared times five I'm sorry, eight over five.
So so there's a nice relation and there were these s these SRN squares.
Ah ah ah ah. Fairly, fairly tractable.
And to summarize what we could what we could prove in general is that S of A plus B squared.
It's less than S of A squared times.
A plus B, minus one over, over.
A minus one and greater than A squared times, A plus B over over A.
I'm pretty sure, like I took it, I took A equals six and B equals three.
And in the previous in the previous case. So so then even though these esq numbers.
Ah, ah, ah, fact fairly weird fractions, we can actually get some easy inequality's here.
And so what I want to do is, is, is is is proof that all of the all of the internal arches stay inside the circle,
all of the outer notches, stay outside the circle, circle back to the picture of the of the of the diagram here.
So what are the Internet. What are the Internet users. OK.
They remind you that then I can draw you in the Internet searches are the following X, the Internet searches occur, for example.
Let's take let's take a. Go back to the computer screen.
This is Notch is X coordinate is S N minus one and the Y code and it is S one.
And then this one is SRN minus two and Y as two and so on.
So it sucks. The internationals occur at S K and S and minus K.
OK, back to the. Back to my formula then, so.
So so I have to I really have to take SCCA. Here's a point.
SCCA s N minus K. This is this is an inner. This is a point where the inner notches and what I want to show is that this is inside the circle.
So that means that s k squared plus S and minus K squared.
The distance. Is it less than S.
And squared. It's what it points to.
I mean, I could take the square root, that's the distance, but then I then had my whole square again.
So. So this is what I this is what I want to prove that that the distance, the square,
the distance to the inner inner notch is less than the square, the distance square, the radius and up.
Well we just about got it. So I can assume that that K is is is let's say greater than or equal to minus K.
So then I can use my formula here and I go for the less than sign and I can see that S of S of K squared is less than or equal to S event minus K.
S of N minus case squared times. OK, so N minus KS is a in this formula.
And and and so, OK, so I take up the sum of these two guys, which is K minus one and and Downbelow.
I take this one, which is in my scheme minus one. It's less than half.
And this in turn.
Let's see, wait a minute. How did I do this? So let's see.
S. S of K squared plus s event minus K squared is less than or equal to.
OK. Well, it should be. If this I guess I blew it.
This is Dan s. Oh, I'm sorry. Then I got to do S. S N squared.
So so s N squared. So so S.
S M squared is some. Now I use my inequality again, so so N minus K is less than as N so.
So I have to. So here I get N minus K minus one. Over N minus one.
And I have to carry this factor over again. So, so, so what I did here is I replaced SRN minus K squared by S N squared times this fraction.
My my my my basic theorem up here and up and well it's casting again.
So this is s a K squared is less than as of.
And screwed. And so now I add. I add the two guys together and I and I get the right inequality.
OK. And and the other way is actually even the other way to show that the outer the outer notches are.
I guess this was the.
This is an internal watch, and I want to show this less, and I also have to show I have to also show that s K squared plus S and plus one minus K.
This is the distance to an outer notch is bigger than s.m squared.
And and the other calculation is just about the same.
We've got this we've got this weight to represent to two things.
And so it is going to turn out that that that that these squares of the S's turn out to act sort of sort of like linear functions of the subscript.
And so it's all going to it's all going to work up.
So. So. So there we are. And.
What I've done is essentially showed you why this formula holds and doesn't take it doesn't take calculus it much just a little bit of sophistication.
But really here we were doing with geometry and that and the thing that that you found is that really because it's because we got a circle here.
And that's why PI is the rising hook. Any questions on this part now?
Yeah, it is hard to Dice's. Why did you.
This. Can we extend it. Joe says fear. Oh yeah.
Good question. I'm going to get to that. Right.
But since you asked that, I might as well show you now because although, you know, I didn't do that in his paper.
He he he found that.
Let's see if I can. I got a picture from him that he sent an.
Yeah. You're gonna zoom in on this.
But here's the kicker here. Here's an example where he takes his.
There was zoom in. So here again, we got the same thing, but but now we've got parallel pipelines.
You've got two boys, you know, instead of instead of rectangles.
And it makes it makes a very nice ball. OK.
So not now that that gives you the formula for four four spheres and also it in dimensions,
it all works with the right, with the with the right multiples of of of PI coming in.
Yeah, good question. Now.
Well, we know that more is true, and so I want to I want to go on.
What we've what we've done so far then is we've we've seen why pie occurs in the in in this population as n now.
Now, how did it get to how do we get that into factories and stuff?
And so let's take a look at this.
It isn't a sabeen again, which which as I remember, was one 1/2 times three fourths and so on.
Until then we had two and minus one or two N. And what we've shown is that this is OK.
So. I'm going to I'm going to say what we've shown is that this is up approximately one over square root of Pi n.
Why I jumped to step here, so let's let's do that slowly.
I got it, I got SRN was equal to two N times A.
And and also I had seen was approximately what the square root of.
OK. So what did I say? We had one pi over four s N squared was approximately N.
And so as soon as approximately square it, you know, as soon as approximate the square root of four for an over pie.
And so if we divide both sides of this equation by two N, we get A and is approximately one over squared pi m.
All right. So, in fact, the in fact, we knew that this was this was Assen was this was.
Pied Piper for Essene Square was actually equal to and plus big, all of one between and plus one and minus one,
which is also I like to read end dates and times one plus vagal of one over in.
So it shows the relative error is of order one over in.
And so what we, what we actually boils down to then we've shown the A.N. is one over is equal to one
over square root of pi end times relative error of one with Biegel of one over in,
in there. OK.
So, so now ace event also it is is a famous number because it, it arises in connection with a so-called drunkard's walk or a random walk where you,
where you go at every step, you flip a coin and you either move to the left or to the right with equal probability.
And so we take a walk of insteps.
And it's another way that you think about it is that suppose you're flipping a coin and you and
you gain a dollar every time you get heads and you lose a dollar every time you you get tails.
So it turns out that A is the probability that if you do it, if you flip a coin too,
and times it's the probability that that that you you you come back exactly.
Balanced exactly the same number of has the stales. Why is that the probability that we have the same this the same number hasn't tails is
is is is two and choose and divided by four to the end or divided by two to the two.
If we flip a coin two times then the how many of those times.
How many of the cases. Two to the end possibilities have.
Exactly. End heads and hand and tails. And that's sort of the definition of, of binomial coefficient two to n things taken at the time.
So that's equal to one one over two to two and times, you know, to end, to end minus one down to one divided by N down to one and end down to one.
But now it turns out that's exactly what any we've got to divide this up.
But that's what a N is, because we can we can say and is equal to one half times two halves times,
three fourths times for force and so on until we get to two and minus one.
And we throw in another factor too. And over to the end we just multiplied by one in here.
But now what we've got in the numerator is two in factorial and in the denominator.
I've got N factorial squared times, two to the two end.
So so this is equal to two N factorial over and factorial squared times.
Two to the two. So, so. So that's what a n. And so, so what we've what we've shown here with this argument is that low and behold,
the probability that we have a balance sequence after two and flips of a coin is is incorrect.
It is very close to one over squared pioneered the relative errors.
You said so. So I got. So I decided, OK.
Let me let me show you what happens when we flip a coin. And.
Go back to the computer now. So.
Took a bunch of quiet flips.
I decided instead of using a random random coin, I would use duck goose pie because, you know, that's that's the point of this lecture.
And so I take it. So let's consider the dust, the binary digits of pi over over four and and see what happens if.
And so here I go up a start. It starts with a one one one zero one zero zero one.
I got a jingle for remembering this. If you want to know, you know, so.
OK. So it goes up, up, down, down, up, down. So. And it looks a little bit like the stock market.
Do you see here? In fact, you know, people think that pie is forced to be random.
But let's see. It returns back to.
It returns back to zero again, I think after six thousand three hundred steps or something like that before it comes back.
Yeah. Yeah.
The next step. Anyway, it it's it it's definitely the zeros are are winning off quite a ways after that.
But but here's a it's a typical it's a typical random walk and and the the the former that we proved
that you remember that we proved that age is the sum of AKCA times N minus K is equal to one.
So this is the same as saying that the summation of binomial coefficient to K choose K times binomial to N minus two, K minus.
Over N, minus K. Divided by some is equal to four to the N.
It turns out it's equivalent to former. That we proved for the A's is equivalent to this to this one.
And that's kind of interesting because it says that you take any any random walk of length to N.
They refer to the unpossible. There are four of the unpossible ways to do it.
And it turns out that that's equivalent to doing two balanced walks.
So I can imagine a walk that that you're going on a plane.
And you start out and you go either east or west and you and you go and you go to two K steps that are either east or west.
And then. And then after you finish going east and west.
And then you take the remaining two and minus two K steps to going either north or south, then it you know, that's at the end.
And then you say you got to get back. You've got to get back home.
So. So the number of steps that where you're going.
Always east to west. And then always north or south. And then.
But you insisted that you first do the horizontal than the vertical. The number of steps back to the origin is exactly the total number of every
random walk that can be can be written as somehow a combination of two balanced,
random words. Now, that's interesting because we know a lot of random walk is also a sequence of zeros and ones,
and we can encode any sequence of zipp so we can call code any sequence of two end bits
as as two sequences that are balanced with the number of zeros and ones are possible.
You know, this is kind of interesting because a lot of people are you are using graphical examples of bitmap these days.
We got you know, my wife just got from the airplane and, you know, this was her.
This was on her boarding pass.
And then there there are these kinds of of visible codes that that people are using.
And even more common I've been seeing now, it was on one of the things I bought today for Christmas was this.
This kind of a pattern that people can take can read with their cell phones.
And it is easy to check now. So so there's a way of a repeat of putting bitmap stent into these into these patterns.
And what we want to have is so that the bitmap is all white or all black, you'd like to have it sort of balance between white, black.
But you still want to be able to handle an arbitrary, arbitrary pattern of of.
You know, you don't have four and bits. And so in a way, this is it.
This is this gives a kind of a perfect balanced code.
In fact, in fact, there's a real simple way to do the real simple way to prove discriminatorily,
which is what I want to show you now with the computer thing to me.
So can we go back to the computer? Oh, I see.
Jason, have you got the guy? OK.
Please give me the computer, not your picture. There must be a way for me to.
To push a button. OK. So here's our here's our walk again. What ups?
What happened? It's. I'm sorry, I.
I, I, I've drawn the coordinates badly from how it went went down.
OK, well, I put a little error there, but I can imagine that I've I've got a blue line going.
Oh, where I left out that blue line. I know. All right. OK.
So what I've done here is I take an arbitrary and arbitrary sequence of of in this case a hundred
bits is that these are the first hundred bits of pie and and I'm using pie just as an example,
not because it's pie. And and I want to show you how to map this into a balanced up pattern.
And Downbelow is going to be it's going to be a set of two balanced.
There'll be a value of K which which says that if the first two K steps are balanced and and then with the last two N minus two K steps,
one hundred minus two K steps are also balanced. And so what I have to do is start with any,
any pattern of zeros and ones and convert it into a pattern that has the same number of
zeros and ones up to up to two K and then the same number as there is one after two K.
And and the theorem identity says that, in fact, this is going to be a sort of a perfect encoding, that there's going to be always a way to do this.
And it's and they end up a lot of people have thought of ways to do it.
But I think this is by far the simplest and it's the following you you first set up the
place where the dividing line occurs is the last place that you that you hit zero.
So in any sequence, it starts at zero and then it has a certain last time that comes to zero.
And it's right here. After 20 after 32 steps now and then, what I know I have to do is take the rest of it.
That that that starts at zero and never, ever touches zero again and convert that into a balanced path.
And so there's got to there's got to be a simple rule that takes us from any
anything that never gets back to zero and converts that into a balanced path.
And conversely, any backdowns path to one of those things that never, never comes back to zero.
And OK, the way I do it, as I'm doing it.
If we zoom in here, we'll see that I actually change these guys up to red.
If it was the it was the last time coming through this row.
So the last time on the third row was red. Here, here, here's red here.
And I put a red guy here, Arregui here and so on.
And and so I now know what I do is after this transition point, I change some of the red red guys that were going downwards and make them go upward.
And the rule is the rule is very simple. I know. I know. I show you back on the path.
So here here we have a path that that starts to zero and never comes back to zero again.
Six or so in here is going negative and it's never going positive. So.
So any such path that, you know, starts out with a downstroke and then did a certain.
It goes and waves around a while but never comes up to zero again and gets finally for the last time at this level.
And then it goes down again.
And then there's a down period and it comes here and it goes and so on until finally it ends at some at some place here, minus two m f it.
And so what I know is that these this these parts never you know, they they start end here and they never go up.
So. So I have essentially at m of these things. And what I do is, is I simply change it so that it goes it, it, it instead of going down it goes up.
And I do that for the first M of them. And the last M keep coming down so that I'm going to have something that looks like this
is going to go up and then it's going to come down and it's going to end up balanced.
OK. So it's very simple. I cut if I found out that in this case, like I wound up I think at minus 10.
And so I. So I converted five of these red guys.
OK. All right. From from down to up.
And that was the. That's the mapping that that makes a perfect map, a perfect way to balance any any any method linked to it.
Now, the last thing I want to mention is that this is all tied in with this with something I lectured about in the ninth.
Lecture from some years ago where we talked about the Christmas the Christmas tree pattern and see the
fastest way for me to get the Christmas tree pattern is probably to go here to the Japanese translation.
Now, this is the this is Hungarian. OK. So. OK.
Christmas tree pattern looked like this. And and can we get it on there?
OK. It's this is the Christmas tree pattern of Order eight and it.
And if we can zoom in and you know what you but it looks a little bit like a Christmas tree from from afar.
But when we zoom in. It's just a pattern of our eight zeros and ones.
And the idea is that every all possible bites and all possible eight combinations appear somewhere in here.
And the ones that are balanced are in the middle, although all the middle guys have had four ones and four zero.
Everything that has five ones and three zeros is in this columns.
And the mapping that I just showed you for how to how to show that there's as many paths that never get back to zero as our balance.
It turns out to be a very nice special case, IDUs of this pattern.
And I think possibly Professor Wata in Japan is watching this lecture now.
And I can assure you the Christmas card that he had, he sent me last year.
Let's see, we zoom zoom out here because I got this from him last year for Christmas.
What he did is he took the Christmas tree pattern on Order of Voters six.
And then he did the teaching of the characters for the for the evening and arranged them instead of zeros and ones in this in this pattern.
So this was a nice, nice present from his.
He's the man who is in charge of translating my books into Japanese the.
So. So this Christmas tree pattern turned out to also be a nice way to prove that identity about binomial coefficient now.
And over time. So I got it. But I do have one. One more thing.
Thing that I got to show you. And that is that the method that that we use for for showing PI also not only does it give three dimensions,
as the guy mentioned, but we can do other.
We can do other things. And so instead of having circles of we, we can also do we can also consider a super list.
People know what a super ellipsis. So so the circle is defined by the by the equation X squared plus Y square equals R squared.
But a super ellipse is is X to the alpha.
Let's say one over Alpha plus. Why is one over?
Alpha equals out of the one over Alpha. And I write one over Alpha because up the case, alpha equals one half is the case.
That is the case that that corresponds to a circle.
And so you might say what happens, for example, if Alpha is equals to one third.
And so that was consider the equation executed.
Plus, why cubicle our cube? Then instead of circles, you get something which I can show on the computer.
This is the picture that that corresponds to execute, plus like you equal our cube.
And what are the the coefficients that the ace in this case?
Well, in fact, instead of being one half of this guy is one third.
And this guy is one third times for six. And then it's time, seven nights and so on.
So we start out with one third.
In general, we start out with Alpha and then then we go to Alpha plus one and Alpha plus two for this general super live.
And the the area now is not going to be equal to.
I mean, you have to figure out what's the area of the of the brown guys, what's the area of the yellow guys and so on.
But that formula also turns out to be easy. And if we had more time, we could work it out.
But but at understate the results now. And the answer that we get is the problem.
So the area. The area.
OK, so we have the same formulas as before, and almost all the argument almost works without without change and generalizing from.
From from Alph equals one half to arbitrary offer works pretty much without without change.
Ace a7 is is is somehow minus alpha. Choose N times minus one of the N and S seven is equal to minus one minus alpha choose N minus one.
And SBN instead of being equal to two Alpha s advantage is is a three is up
and over alpha times a sabeen instead of two and a sabeen and then the that.
Then we have B Sabeen which is the,
which is the area of the of a particular strip a zero a what up to A and B zero B seven was equal to one in the previous case, but in the Pi case.
But in this case it's, it's equal to. Well, one minus.
Alpha over and. Minus one.
And and then the area of the rectangle. Instead of being N is the sum of is Bisa of one up to be sort of N minus one.
And that turns out to be. And in minus one.
OK. In the case, Elphick was one third, it was in minus Alpha over N minus one.
And I can convert that to I could convert that into a formula like the other guy, which would just be, I think, to mine it to myself.
I guess I have to not try. I'm sure of this formula, Pritish.
Anyway, so. So what are they.
The idea of an all boils down instead of saying that the that we've got a formula for PI in terms of these these rectangles,
the direct angles now approach a Super Lipps beautifully and the earth.
And so so we get the funding for the area of a Super Lipps.
X to the one over Alpha,
plus I do one over Alpha equals one is and did the sequel to two alpha times the gamma function of Alpha squared over the gamma of two Alpha.
This is. So anyway, did you get gamma function is like a factorial and it it's when alpha is equal to one half.
Gamma of one half is the square root of pi and gamma one is equal to one.
And so this turns out to be pi.
But in general then that the whole the whole argument also proves things that it's somehow without calculus related to the gamma function.
And he question. Yeah. I mean, you know what, I what I really ought to do is, is it is be careful about this.
So what I have is is a sabeen is the coefficient.
Hey, Esteban, is that is somehow the coefficient of one over.
Well, when mine is read to be alpha. It's a coefficient of leader the N in this.
And so then. S of N is going to be the coefficient of C to the N minus one.
In what way might I see the alpha plus one.
And then not be event is going to be equal to the sum of that.
So this is going to be over two alpha.
It should be two alpha really. When I said one myself, it should have been two alpha.
I was thinking one third and twice. One third is two.
So and so then t n which is the sum of the which which is the area is actually then one.
It's a it's one plus two zie the coefficients of this.
So, so. So it's actually two, two alpha gets in there instead. That's why the two Alphas.
Yeah. So. So the. Anyway in order to, in order to calculate the area of a Super Lipps by, by calculus,
you have to you have to evaluate integral that I didn't know how to you know,
I mean are you good at integrating the cube root of of X plus one minus X.
Sorry. Executed plus when my as X cubed the integral from zero to one of this.
That's the that's it. Turns out to be two thirds.
Times gamma of one third squared over. Gamma.
Two thirds. Motivation was the second time came up in the asking products for large numbers.
I guess the Australians want me to use this environment to prove Australians.
I didn't hear. Sorry. So I was. So the original motivation was the three times.
Right. I was wondering if there was a way to frame Stone's formula differently using like this.
Yes. OK, that's that's that's in fact that's one of the that's that's exercised nine.
OK. In concrete math, it's it's actually one of the largest exercise in the book.
And it has a problem that that Marco shoots of Asia asked me in conversation some years ago.
And. And it's unknown how to get the whole story formula from this.
But we're very, very close. And if I didn't have time to go on to go into your hands.
I thought it would take. I didn't think would take me this long to want to go through when I had.
So I have had a lot of other material. And we tell you what I would I would have said if I had more time.
First of all, if you took a joke.
I know. But what you know, the first thing that goes when you retire is a sense of time.
So it's not too hard to prove that Stirling's formula with calculus anyway.
If it's fairly easy to prove that that in factorial is approximately and over to the end times, the squared of in time some constant.
But now, in order to actually in order to but even he.
But now I don't know of a real good way to prove that without calculus.
But but there is. But there are some there are some ways that where we don't we don't really need it.
But if we allow to use logarithms, then suppose that the logger and factorial is equal to say any any polynomial in in n and log in.
And you can throw in some other functions to participles.
So so, for example, Stirling's formula says that is in times log in minus N plus one half log in plus some constant.
OK. So this is a plus plus something that goes to zero.
So little then let's set something that that's negotiables and goes to infinity.
OK. Now but but but the fact is that you're suppose I suppose they have the summation of ace of IJA times into the eye and log into the J for example.
And I don't even require that I injia integers now.
But then we've proved that ace of n is is is that you.
Which there's two in factorial over. Over in factorial squared.
Transferred to the N is up is approximately one over squared pi n o.
And if you look at this, the only possible form,
the only thing that works is it is when it's a N log N minus capitally N plus one half at log N plus some constant which would make this happen.
Because, because otherwise this wouldn't cancel out to give you just a square root factor.
OK. So, so if we, if we assume though that if the function is of this form then you just plug into this formula and you see that C has to be squared.
Add two pi. Now, the remaining question is why E!
And I don't have a combinatorial answer to that. There's a long winded one, but it's not satisfactory.
And so until I would love to, I'd love to know why. Combinatorial Lee.
Yeah. So, you know, it seems it seems to rely on the best.
The best thing I have so far requires arguing about infinite products.
I have to know that the product of of one plus Biegel of one over in squared converges to infinity.
If I'm given that, then I can come up with an argument that explains,
like I can show why it comes in here using some inclusion in inclusion properties and things like that.
And the end and the basic the basic thing seems to be equivalent to something like this.
The N plus one plus one over and race to the end plus.
One half power is equal to E times with with relative error of of one over and squared.
And somehow everything that I do, I tried in order to get a commentary approved for requires finding commentary, a reason why this is true.
So we have to know what it is and we have to know what we have to somehow show that this is a very good approximation.
And I'd love to see a geometric proof of this, that this thing, because then then we would be close to his answer and just behave properly.
I'm going to trial, Chris.
But there's another situation which there's a formula involving PI and comes up in the convergence of a series where it's kind of unexpected.
There's some of the inverse squares as PI split over six. It's like, what do I have to do?
Squares. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Johan has a has a has a nice proof of that.
That's what we're using for your series for your Syria. And when your original capital of was like a polynomial, our expansion,
which got me thinking about if there is a four year series proof Stirling's approximation,
where the factorial like you take the log in and that becomes Asama and then you can use it for your series argument.
Yeah, well, I average explaining this right.
We, we wanted to minimize trigonometry. We want to.
And so what I like about your proof is that you don't need signs and cosigns even.
Yeah, but we didn't need to, to calculate the U.
S s k squared plus and minus K squared. But that was done with real simple inequalities.
So. But yeah. With you know, with enough tools we can we can all we can do it.
Sterling did it in 1730 before for you know for a hundred years before really.
But but this this way of of of doing it shows the connection with with circles that otherwise
you get from some business such some integral like like a beta integral or something.
Seems to me set now. Yeah.
I wanted to say something else about that. Let's see. Oh yeah. There are also other combinatorial problems like suppose you suppose you you
have a random map from from the set of integers one to n into the same set.
You know, so. So you have if this is some some mapping slips when you start out you say one F of one F F of one.
And so on. And you keep on repeating this until you get a value for the second time.
Now, the expected time, the number of steps that you do this turns out to be,
I think it's like one plus one half the square root of PI and or something like that.
I mean, there's something there's something square to PI and comes into this formula.
Here's if this is a case where I don't see why there's any connection of circles.
OK. Question. Question on this, do. Can I go?
So you mentioned random walks here thinking about random well as to bounce random loss.
Yeah, I'm curious. How close can you get the length of the two balanced random locks?
Well, in fact, it's it's it's if you look at the distribution of K, it seems that the extremes are K zero Kaiko that are the most common.
And then it gets sort of it goes like that I think is something like the square root of of K.
Times Square of N minus K. So this squared of K over, and if something like this.
The probability distribution of K is something like one over of one over squared of X, one minus X, something like that.
How was it when X is one half, it's them. It's the least common case.
And when X is what is it at the extremes, it's the most come. So, so.
So when you apply in any of these transformations, it turns out that it's not.
It's it's least likely to be in the middle where I draw the line between the two bouncing, but still not that unlikely.
It's you know, it's it's it's like one over squared and or something like that.
Anyway, it's most it's a.
The distribution of K is highest at the at the ends but it.
But you know, you have to integrate it over over to insteps, over insteps and plus one step.
Actually I came up with a with a better code for four balanced codes, some musical easier to decode.
Look where you take a.
I have a paper that came out about 30 years ago where we're at, where I have n two to the to to the K information bits and end and K parody bits.
And so like, you know, K is eight and I have turned 64 bits and I come up with a balance.
You give me any, any byte. And I can give you the corresponding a balanced set of 2k of of 264 bits that represents that by, with, with it.
Again, a simple. Is it easy to code.
Easy to decode. And it's probably. It's probably better if I wanted to transform this other one.
I have to I have to send a balanced set of bits and then I have to somehow tell people what K
is that that's just OK that Kate and have to be Kate small so it doesn't have to be balanced.
But in this case, the whole thing was bound.
Yeah, there's lots of questions come up around this that are that are quite interesting, I think that's that's why I came late.
So much stuff to say today. Yeah.
Where do you get the shirt? They're like, oh, the shirt is made by a Laotian woman who died a few years ago, but they let her daughter.
Discovered my daughter on Facebook a week ago. So I know I got a whole bunch of people from Facebook in the front row here, so I can mention that.
But I my wife gave it to me as a Christmas present some years ago, and I traditionally wear it at this lecture.
So. Yeah. I can't stop thinking about the last question you posed with the tape,
the period of the permutation group or the conditions you placed on and on the last sheet that you had read.
The conditions that I placed on F. Is it is it if the probability it's random.
So so it's the end of the impossible functions. End of the unpause.
No one can be anything, anything for one day in everything.
No, it's not a permutation. It's a mapping. I'm saying if I have a random mapping, when do I get into a loop?
It. If F is a permutation, then, you know, it might be that I have to go through everything.
But but but in fact, if F takes everything into one, then I'm stuck right after the second step.
So you think you see what I mean by the fact that there's a great computer algorithm based on this?
If you want to if if if somebody says find a fine, you give me a table and numbers from one end and and somebody says,
what's a good way to find two items on the table that are equal to each other?
And the answer is you. You started the first one.
And and and if that's five, then you go to the fifth one and if that's eight, then you go to eighth one.
That's three. And you keep on going until you come to something twice again. And then you've then you found these two things.
And suddenly taking your butt square to pie and steps before you found two elements that are equal in disarray.
And this is true if if if the mapping is random. But in the worst case, you'd have to look at everything.
And. And it might be that it's a permutation in which which case there aren't any.
What? You would discover that. Yeah, well, you're nothing to walk on a balanced block.
You never mentioned how you can get back and how many are attributing you to.
Oh, yeah. So.
So I had these I had these these two M triangle triangles.
Right. And I moved I moved everything up by M so.
So then you look at your balance walk and you see how high is it.
And that's m and so. And so.
So then you can figure out what the red guys are. This time you go from the left instead of from the right.
And and that tells you which five to lower down. Yeah.
Greg, good question. Your title of one of these books. Well, thank you all.
And have a merry Christmas.